this is probably the most simplistic
sentence that i genuinely this is not
some foofy foofy let's do a show [ __ ]
this is real as [ __ ] to me
everybody who's standing right now the
quickest way for your business to get
much much bigger
is for you to realize right now every
single thing that's wrong in your
company is not johnny or sally's fault
it is 100 your fault because you [ __ ]
hired johnny and sally
you've got your perspective
[Applause]
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
when i think about why would you be here
fair
fair
i love you too
[Applause]
when i think about why you you would
love me
it would be from a place of all of us
want to make our lives better
you know and the people we love better
right and
i think one of the great mistakes so
many people that follow me
and think they've got my message down
make
is they make content for their
self-interest not for their audience
they don't understand that by making
content for their audience there's a
very good chance over a decade period of
time their self-interest will come
through the amount of people that i see
give me love dm me say this nice things
to me they're about me this and that and
when i spend five minutes analyzing
their social media execution it's very
disheartening for me
because they're picking and choosing
what they hear from me
to do what i do and what i see others do
that is successful
whether it's a person a brand a business
you have to do all parts of it
people love to see the part of tenacity
but they struggle a little bit more with
patience
people love when to think that they're
giving
and they're giving
but they struggle to see that they're
giving with manipulation
and with intent of something for
themselves which is the furthest thing
from giving in the world
so i think what's really interesting as
i go into this next chapter of my career
is i've got to push myself
harder
to get into the depths of the nuances
and the little tiny context points
that make what i do work
with the hope
that you can have it too one of the
crazy things that has become obvious to
me in the last decade is
the reason i give away everything i've
got is because i don't think if you then
go take it and do well that that comes
out of my pocket
i'm fascinated by how many people hold
things back
because they don't think
or realize that the world is
fundamentally abundant
everyone is so scared that if they give
away their best advice or their best
content
that somebody's going to take that and
run with it
i dinner with my dad two days ago which
was really nice and he reminded me of a
story when i was a kid
i went to a
industry liquor store in new jersey
industry event
and i walked around and was telling
other liquor store owners
about how well winelibrary.com was doing
and why email was the future
and when we got back in my dad
talked about like
us not
like that was bad
like why would you tell them they're
gonna do it they're going to take our
customers
and i looked at my dad and i said they
can't steal my brain
and it reminded me of who i was when i
was 17 1921
which is just
a younger less experienced version of
who i am today
but what i promise you is
as we all sit here today without knowing
exactly
what santino or ben or whoever has in
mind of what they want to do
whether you're in b2b or b2c whether
you're in real estate or crypto
content
have your own agency sell sneakers
it's very easy for me to talk to this
room because there are certain things
that no matter what you are even if
you're not an entrepreneur
if you're a stay-at-home parent
if you are a teacher
if you are running for political office
there are things that are incredibly
consistent about the human race
i was an atrocious student but the one
class i was consistently strong at was
history
and i never really understood why
until i got
into this last decade of my life when i
started understanding myself better on
how i roll
and it's because history just tells me
the future
we're consistent
we're animals we are who we are
and we
only navigate
through one framework
our actual perspective on life
every single person here is navigating
every single day predicated on how they
see it how they see it is predicated on
how they grew up their environment their
dna their parenting
the most interesting to me
what they are currently listening to
or whom
the thing that's really interesting to
me
is
if you turn your head to the left
you see it different than if you turn
your head to the right and what i've
been trying to spend a lot of time on
over the last 15 years of my life
first subconsciously now consciously is
i just want
people to be happier because it makes me
personally feel good to make people
happy
to be incredibly transparent i also feel
a level of guilt because as i've come to
know the world better i've come to
realize how incredibly lucky i am
and look for entrepreneurs like me
who've worked their face off their whole
life luck is a tricky word because as
you know and i'm sure people in your
life have done this people love to throw
out luck
as a thing to make themselves feel
better about somebody who's doing well
they use it when they have envy or
jealousy and that's fine
but
i'm incredibly lucky i
grew up in a perfect storm
of situations that gave me what i have
i have
the luxury
of being born in adversity
just like this lovely lady flew from
moscow like where we're from
where i was born
what people don't you know what most
people in the world don't realize is the
soviet union in its 70-year run you
weren't allowed to leave the country
like leave it it was for all intents of
purposes jail
and so
the fact that i was born in that place
at the time where some people were able
to leave
that's luck
the fact that i get to go to america
a foundational country in our society
that cherishes and applauds
entrepreneurship when i was born a
purebred entrepreneurship
luck
the fact that i was an immigrant and
you know for all the immigrants in here
you know
immigrant life in that first half decade
or decade is basically about food and
shelter you're not worried about [ __ ]
fresh kicks
you're worried about [ __ ] eating and
so when you have that and then you have
a little bit of a frugal mom like i did
my parents didn't buy me [ __ ]
which trained me as an animal that i had
to go get mine
that was a luxury
it's hard to be hungry when you're
always fed
and so that was luck
but the biggest luck i had by a country
mile
is that i had a mother who built such a
framework
of perspective for me
and balanced
confidence and self-awareness
but also
ramifications eliminating delusion she
created such a framework
that i had no chance but not to win
i think the world
is about communication
period
i think there's nothing else
i think the world is based on
communication
it's how everybody does everything
communication is why this world is
religion based
the printing press is invented a new
form of communication
books
the
disproportionate leader of printing
books in the first two decades of the
printing press
were religious institutions
and here we are hundreds of years later
and our society is framed on it
in a much more small way
google adwords come out in 2000
the number one advertiser on that
platform for the first five years is
amazon
and it is the foundation of why they're
one of the biggest companies in the
world besides the talent of the
executives
for me life is crazy simple and i'm
desperately trying to get this room to
make it crazy simple
is what it is
it is based on
the opportunity to communicate so that
you can achieve what will make you happy
and it's predicated on what you are
trying to accomplish based on who you
actually are
after that everything becomes incredibly
secondary after that level of
self-awareness and understanding of how
the world operates
you can decide what you want to do you
can then focus on your passion trying to
maximize your dollars or whatever else
tickles your fancy
the problem is the simplicity of the
framework
is something people struggle with
tremendously
as many of you probably know
the other thing that drives me today is
i think that negativity
is dramatically louder than positivity
i believe if you analyze the world
social media mainstream media
your household
negativity is loud
positivity tends to be quiet because
it's got internal strength to deal with
the negativity and it doesn't bother
itself with the negativity
because of that we have a world that is
louder about bad
and quieter about good
when this became obvious to me seven
nine five years ago
i felt an incredible
and incredible energy
of
conviction
and really just honestly accountability
i felt like
i had to get loud about the truth of the
world
and here's the truth
the world is better today than it's ever
been in the history of mankind
yet so few people believe it
i love when all my friends are like gary
you [ __ ] [ __ ] social media ruined the
world look what's going on i'm like wait
you loved mainstream media you mean 1920
to 1990 when the world was at the height
of dictatorship and fascism war what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
we are incredibly incredibly capable of
misunderstanding the situation
we can do it in the macro
and then to bring it way down for me to
get off my philosophy train and get into
the trenches with you
it's the biggest reason most of your
businesses don't grow the way you want
to you are misreading the situation
the reason i talk about the things i
talk about is for example as all of you
are trying to build how many people here
by show of hands have five or more
employees in a company they run raise
your hands stand up actually stand up
stand up if that's you
more than five
more than five your business
all right
please stand don't be bashful you try to
five yeah you're good first let's clap
it up for these winners
now
now
now
this is very important
for the people that are standing
the number one
most obvious thing that i see every day
of my life over the last 20 years
is they think
somebody in their company
is at fault for something without
realizing it's their fault
this is the breakthrough
you like that one
you're excited about that
anybody who's standing right now
just this is the easiest my favorite
framework this is probably the most
simplistic sentence that i genuinely
this is not some foofy foofy let's do a
show [ __ ] this is real as [ __ ] to me
everybody who's standing right now
the quickest way for your business to
get much much bigger
is for you to realize right now every
single thing that's wrong in your
company is not johnny or sally's fault
it is 100 your fault because you [ __ ]
hired johnny and sally
you can sit
this is a very big deal this is like
funny to me i am shocked that we now
live in 2021 in a world where bosses
don't want accountability
where where are we accountability
the reason the world is so tense and the
reason the world is so upset
is because people don't like
accountability
we love to point fingers we hate to
point thumbs
you could still be right
but the act of pointing your thumb
makes it better
let me say that slowly
i take accountability for everything
that's wrong in my businesses easily it
has become second nature
logically
i often think i'm right
and johnny and sally are wrong logically
but in real truth
i am the one who hired their boss's boss
uh how many people here
own a v friend raise your hand
thank you
if any of those people how many of you
if you're in here does anybody here own
a gift goat
my man
stand up for this goat
so
you
you
out of all these people may know what
happened this week
correct so thank you i just want to
confirm that there is a human that knows
what i'm about to tell you is true it's
him
all right
this week
we
you know
nfts are decentralized anonymous
web 3. but
the world is still predominantly web 2.
gift goat was a token i sold in nft land
where you own the token but you also get
18 physical gifts
from me over the course of three years
as you can imagine i'm gonna need to
have an address to send it to you thus i
need information
we're going through that whole process
with that small group of 555 token
holders i got about i still held a bunch
so call it a community of three to four
hundred
even though we have a clear system even
though four people around it are super
strong been with me for a long time as
my friend here knows this week we sent
an email to all the gift goat holders to
confirm a continuation of something we
need to finish this process off
the team completely
completely didn't follow protocol and
decided to send a regular email instead
of through mailchimp in a server
and send
it
with everybody's email in the
cc yeah
now
the reality is
in a non-custodial environment of nft
land there's a lot of mistakes you have
to do to get something stolen from you
and just having one's email is not going
to be the death blow but it's a piece
that could get to a death blow if the
person on the other side
and others make two or three other
critical mistakes
the insanity of this mistake
was high like
comments in the discord for gift goats
only of like how do we have confidence
everything they're saying they're right
it was such an amateur mistake we
haven't made that mistake on regular
garyvee [ __ ] monday morning emails
saying what's up to you
this they're hypersensitive to
information
within
so here's what happens i come out of a
meeting in l.a
i get the tech i you know and so just
like
in two seconds i'm like
like right blood to the head like
wind out of chest because i know it's
going to
one
cause some anxiety for my community
them
two
back to me
first them now me
first oh [ __ ] there's gonna be a couple
people that own this thing that are
gonna be anxious and i feel bad
next
me which is really not me next oh [ __ ] i
have four employees right now that are
scared shitless and they're anxious
next me
oh [ __ ] i don't have two hours but the
next two hours are [ __ ] completely
destroyed because i have to go into full
damage control and community building to
make sure my community knows that i
don't think this is a good thing and
i've got to fix it
and that's what i did
within 39 seconds of knowing the
situation i recorded an entire video
taking on accountability and post in the
community and then spent the next hour
and a half with the community in discord
why do i tell you that story i tell you
that story because i actually believe in
accountability
my biggest concern is that i know
there's a lot of people here consume my
content leave comments dm me engage
they talk my talk but they don't live my
talk
i get more emails from people that
are the employees of people
who love me and talk about me all day
to tell me
that
rick loves you i have no idea what
you're talking about but rick's
completely full of [ __ ]
he talks like you talk he repeats your
[ __ ]
but he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that rick story is super common
i know there's a ton of ricks in this
room right now i know it more than the
sun will come up tomorrow you talk that
garyvee [ __ ] you don't live that garyvee
[ __ ]
and where you don't live it is not on
the hustle and grind you don't live it
on the kindness and humanity you don't
live it on the empathy and about that
100
[ __ ] hundred percent
and i don't say that on stage to come up
here and like i'm good and scolding you
i'm coming on stage saying cut that [ __ ]
out i promise you if you listen to this
it's real
it's real
the reason i pound patience down
everyone's throat and everyone hates the
flavor of it
is because once you have a framework of
patience it eliminates so much bad
behavior
patience is important because most
people can't see
like the way i set up this talk can't
see that most of the [ __ ] they do
is for affirmation from other people
people can't see that most of the [ __ ]
they do
is to get credit from other people
normally toxic relationships whether
parents
siblings
plus ones or my favorite thing to hate
because i hate the word hate but i hate
this
so many of you live your life
based on the comments from strangers on
social media
people here don't post certain [ __ ]
because they don't think it's going to
get enough likes
people post certain [ __ ] that they're
not even about anymore because they
think it's gonna get a bunch of likes
people are scared to make video content
when they know video content works
because they're scared the way they look
and they don't want people to say they
don't look good
the world runs on a currency of people
trying to get affirmation from others
people buy [ __ ] they can't afford do
[ __ ] they don't want to do all to
impress people they don't even like
[Applause]
the opportunity
for you to accomplish whatever the [ __ ]
you're up to right now is never been
greater than it is right now we are
thank you
we are at full scale of web 2
from tick tock to face meta from tick
tock
to meta
[ __ ] that's gonna be hard um from tick
tock to meta to youtube to podcast
you are now pretty much capable of
reaching almost any person on earth if
you're good enough
my favorite other non-accountable thing
my instagram is down because meta wants
me to just run ads and they're [ __ ]
with the algorithm these [ __ ] [ __ ]
my favorite part of that is not true
rick
here's what's actually happening
from facebook to tick tock to twitter to
youtube
they're just a blank supply and demand
machine
they all start out the same way
how many people here by show of hands
have been following me long enough that
when i get crazy and got crazy on tick
tock three years ago you listened and it
worked out for you raise your hands
let's clap it up for them that's awesome
so for the people that just raised their
hands
for the people that just raised their
hands was that the first platform that
you built a big community raise your
hand
perfect so for those hands
what they realized when they went
through it was oh what gary's been
saying consistently is right you can
start at zero when a platform
has a ton of people consuming but not a
ton of people making content and the ads
haven't started yet it's just supply and
demand there's people consuming there's
people making
the third variable that always happens
is eventually that platform adds an
advertising product and over time more
money goes into it but there's still
just one feed
it's just supply and demand it's real
estate
it's the algorithm
the algorithm isn't trying to trick you
into spending ads you're just not better
than everybody else
you're not funnier
you're not better looking
you're not smarter
the algorithm is truth
your subjective feelings
are false
this is a good thing this isn't bad this
is awesome
when you realize that's true you realize
oh crap there are people still exploding
out of nowhere on youtube even though
it's at scale
when you realize that you're like oh
crap there are people crushing on
instagram right now even though the
majority of us me included organic
reaches down
they're innovating they're adjusting
they go from a picture looking good with
lighting to making a reels because
that's how the algorithm is working
the amount of humility that i find in
the business world is staggeringly low
the amount of humility that i see in the
business world is staggeringly low
why do i keep finding things like nfts
and tick tock and youtube and facebook
and twitter and email and why is my
career my career
it's based on two things
curiosity and humility do you think i
had a lot of time in december in january
this last year to spend on reading about
something called nfts you think i had
those 50 60 70 hours a week extra to
keep digging in
in january i did not
what i had was curiosity and humility
curiosity because my spidey senses said
there's something [ __ ] happening
and by listening and reading all your
dms and comments
all that time i put in that's how i
stumble on [ __ ]
but way more importantly than that
humility
i have friends
when i ping them in
january and said you need to google this
[ __ ] you need to watch some of these
youtube videos you need to read about
this nft they replied with my time's too
valuable
yeah you know where this next line's
going
i am fascinated
fascinated by the lack of humility to
create innovation in the entrepreneur
and business world
people value their time and my favorite
part is this has now become very clear
to me the people that tend to value
their time the most in my world when i
really analyze it are the peoples whose
time is the least valuable
they're built on some straight facade
ego
they think they're somebody
they're also and this is a big one
most people continue to be transactional
what's in it for me
for the 30 hours i put in this month
nothing when you innovate
nothing
if you're going to innovate you got to
go build some [ __ ] stay alive until
everybody comes
these are the things that are running
through my mind these are the frameworks
that i think about so much this is
where i'm at at this point of my career
i don't understand
how people don't realize that kindness
is the single strongest foundation to
building a huge business
and let's let's let's have this talk i
really want to have this talk
i'm not on some ideology [ __ ] up here
i'm not on some zen fufu
buddha [ __ ] up here i'm on some i'm a
better businessman than all of you
combined [ __ ] okay that's where i'm at
so let there be no confusion when i talk
over the next five minutes i'm not on
some like let's zen it out let's all be
nice and kumbaya i'm on some i'll
[ __ ] destroy every one of you [ __ ]
hard
[ __ ] okay
this is i have to say this because you
have to hear me
i believe that kindness
is an alpha killer business trait not
some nice additive to the way the world
is today
here's why
it's sustainable
when you're building some how many
people here are building something for
themselves raise your hands
higher
higher
thank you
there's a lot of people doing that in
this room
you have to understand why kindness
matters kindness matters cause you
yourself will feel better and you're the
[ __ ] engine
you have to understand why kindness
matters if you're kind to your employees
they stay longer
continuity matters when you're building
something meaningful
you have to understand why kindness
matters if you don't [ __ ] over your
vendors by not paying them or doing the
right if you do the right thing they
keep doing business with you
you gotta understand why kindness
matters why the [ __ ] did i buy this
sneaker
why
it does look good but why
this
this [ __ ] little swoosh is worth one
trillion dollars
this [ __ ] little swoosh is worth one
trillion
[ __ ] dollars
that's called brand
when you're kind
and you do it for 15 years
you build a reputation
that reputation my friends is called
brand
we
all of us
have been taught way too long for the
last hundred years about business that
it's a dirty game
that it's a sharp elbows game
that if you're nice you'll get walked
all over game
it's not true
and i think it's [ __ ] time we start
talking about it
are you
seriously
it's not true
it's [ __ ] not true it's not true and
it's [ __ ] time that we talk about it
the people that are kindness most
honorable when you're so good that you
have no negative intent for anybody else
that you don't do wrong things you move
fast do you know how many of you waste
unlimited amounts of energy and time
being mad about some dumb [ __ ]
do you know why i out navigate so many
of my competitors i don't waste a minute
on [ __ ] drama
people love some [ __ ] drama
you love a good confrontation
love it
my dad once got so i i once saw my we
had a beer truck delivering beer the
beer truck was leaving
they it's a big truck beer truck the guy
didn't have a lot of room in the parking
lot he ran over
a flower
i saw my dad from the corner
this man was so happy
that he was about to get into a fight
with the beer driver
you would have thought he won the
[ __ ] lottery
he ran so fast he is looking for it
and i said dad you look for
confrontation you got to get better
inside so you have peace so you don't
fight
my friends if you're looking for fights
you're hurt
there is no reason
to be in major confrontations
the people that win in business
the big game not some transactional
small [ __ ] you think you're somebody the
big [ __ ] game
are the people that are capable about
being the bigger person in every
situation
[Applause]
bro where are you going
you better be taking a [ __ ]
go go because the good stuff's coming
my friends i sit here while we have that
little laugh bathroom break and what's
going through my mind is
[ __ ] man i know most these people don't
fully understand what i'm saying right
now
that's that's what's going through i'm
like
i don't i don't know
i'm gonna fight for this forever
we have to get this framework down
because it's super real and it's super
works there are tried and true
principles that are forever and then
what that allows you to do is have time
to look for the new [ __ ] you understand
if you're if you're cruising
over here on the empathy compassion
kindness patience accountability side if
you're cruising if you're cruising
because i promise you whatever is broken
over here it's eating up all the time
if you're insecure you're overthinking
everything
if you're confrontational you're looking
for [ __ ] confrontation
if you're a gossip you're looking to
call your business friend and just [ __ ]
on some other people tearing down other
people's buildings to make yourself feel
better when it's doing nothing for
nobody
when you got this [ __ ] going you have
people was like gary how do you [ __ ]
time i'm not wasting time on dumb [ __ ]
that's how
you know how much energy this [ __ ] takes
my friends
let's make a make a pledge with me right
now
don't
talk [ __ ] about your competitor
don't
talk [ __ ]
about your competitor
let me tell you why one
it's a waste of your ten minutes
two
what's really happening
is you're giving her or him more power
you talking [ __ ] about your competitor
is making your competitor stronger
i don't even know my competitors names
i don't even know they exist
give a [ __ ]
spend zero seconds on it cheering for
them let them do their thing has nothing
to do with me
the world is abundant
nobody on earth is taking your money or
your happiness
your perception that they are is taking
your money and your [ __ ] happiness
this is where we're at
we're at this crossroads where i
genuinely believe that we can reframe
the business world i believe that
business could be a remarkable engine of
good i really do it's got it's got the
pieces in place
inherently it's built on merit
inherently it's built on merit it's got
so many of the ingredients
what it doesn't have
is it doesn't have the full conversation
being talked about
it's to me me me
it's two winner takes all
it's two all that and listen i love to
compete i love to win i love to take
like i love all that [ __ ]
but it's more complex than that and i
want to get people into that framework
i'll go over here and then we'll go into
q a over here
is back to what i said earlier when i
got that great woo from that dude right
there
the opportunity is enormous we have a
full-pledged 25 years in
full-scale
web 2.0 world
social
internet phone it's at scale
the highways have been built
the planes have been built it's at scale
we're all here in our primes it's at
scale
and over here
we have the emerging web 3
decentralized world very similar to what
i grew up in in 1995 with the internet
for the young how many people here over
the ages of 45 raise your hand raise
your hands
you're being a little bashful raise your
hands higher
all right let's clap it up for us old
[ __ ]
not a lot which is amazing
so
for the 45 year olds plus in here we
truly remember i'm looking at some of
you gray hairs now right we remember
actually living our entire childhood
without the internet the whole thing we
fully lived life and understood what the
world was without it
so when it came this is now education
for the youngsters in here especially
the real youngsters like when it came it
was hard for people to understand what
you're seeing right now with nfts is
very similar people can't wrap their
head around it
the same jokes i hear about nfts are the
same jokes i heard about the internet in
1995.
the same person says this is so stupid
i'll just control copy it and i own the
jpeg
no you don't
the same thing i heard which is
gary who's gonna buy
stuff
on the world wide web
my answer was
everyone
in 1995
almost anybody i knew over the ages of
35
thought the answer was
no one
the difference with
web 3 decentralized ethereum bitcoin
this whole world is we have the internet
we didn't have anything else besides the
mainstream media
and the way the world was when the
internet came along so they controlled
the narrative
with the internet around the narrative
is being controlled by a lot of people
not by seven or fifteen
that's changing that's a good thing and
that's a bad thing let me say it very
clear to you all right now i believe
that nfts are going to be one of the
most important things for all of us for
the rest of our lives i also believe
right now that 98 of the nfts that
people are buying are gonna go to zero
and be huge money losses i also believe
the two percent that are out there are
going to be the biggest financial wins
in those people's lives
that's the game
what does that mean like if i'm sitting
there and i haven't discovered this yet
but i believe that gary might be like
what does that mean it means you need to
do 50 hours of homework because i
promise you're not gonna guess your way
to the two percent
right
this is a time for nobody should be you
nobody
nobody should be in this [ __ ] room
right now
that has not spent 50 hours reading or
listening or watching videos about nfts
you shouldn't you're here for me
you shouldn't if you're here for me
then you're of a certain perspective a
certain mindset a certain energy a
certain curiosity a certain ambition
please please please don't make the same
mistake you did by not going hard at tic
toc three years ago or snapchat or all
the other [ __ ] i've been doing for 15
years you all know which one you didn't
do that now turned out to be what it is
please spend 50 hours on this do you
know many of you have an opinion on nfts
without ever studying an hour on ifts
you read one headline or you listen to
one friend that kind of knows something
about something and you formed your
complete opinion about it
we form our opinions on headlines not on
research
all the opportunity is to do the reverse
please spend 50 hours on it because you
have to understand it's contractual
infrastructure it's not about art and
collectibles this is how you're going to
contract
every single thing you do from buying a
home renting a car all of it will be
built on this technology
please pay attention
got it
good
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times
i also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon